und unser erster fall heute abend der
ist der albtraum aller junger frauen
ko-tropfen edith steht fest die frau die
wir ihnen gleich zeigen werden die wurde
opfer dieser drogen jemand betäubte sie
mit ko tropfen und vergewaltigte sie und
ihn steht fest sagt das was mir passiert
ist das könnte jeder anderen frau
genauso passieren und tatsächlich ist in
hamburg gerade es genauso geschehen 6 k
-o -tropfen opfer in einer nacht wer
dahintersteckt nur in altendorf marco
zitzow und chef alexander hahn
recherchiert
ausgelassen feiern den drink nur einen
moment aus den augen lassen und dann
durch ko tropfen betäubt werden caro
tropfen heimtückisch und
lebensgefährlich bei einer überdosis
droht atem stillstand und tod
aktuelle opfer fünf frauen und ein mann
in hamburg in den clubs bka kiez
internat und dem noro auf st pauli
schlagen unbekannte vorvergangenes
wochenende zu tun
unbekannte ihren opfern liquid ecstasy
eine droge unbemerkt ins glas um die
schach matt zu setzen in den meisten
fällen ist der hintergrund dass man
natürlich die hilflosen wehrlosen opfer
dann sehr leicht beklagen kann
brieftaschen bett nimmt kam handys
wegnehmen kann aber es kommt auch immer
wieder zu sexuellen übergriffen
die sechs opfer der st pauli nacht lagen
alle über gedächtnislücken aber was
steckt hinter den attacken
die frauen hatten symptome gesagt dass
sie plötzlich eine technisch verlust
erlitten haben da waren 5 frauen ein
mann dabei und weiteren symptome sind
hinzugekommen wie beispielsweise
schwindel und übelkeit das sind auch
symptome die auftreten können wenn
jemand ko-tropfen konsumiert hat
hinweise auf sexuellen missbrauch oder
raub hat die polizei noch keine vernimmt
erneut die opfer
vor neun jahren passiert der frau von
schauspieler eric steht fest endet das
unfassbare max h vergewaltigt die damals
17-jährige eine stunde lang als sie
regungslos unter k -o -tropfen stand
filmte die tat durch einen zufall
gelangte das video an die polizei bis
2018 wusste edith nichts von ihrem
missbrauch
auf mein handy vom lka berlin mit der
aussage ich soll mit aufs revier kommen
ich solle ein opfer identifizieren geht
um die tat aus leipzig und ich bin dort
hingefahren und dachte es geht um
irgendjemand anderen und wurde dort in
einen raum gebracht und musste mir die
aufnahmen einer vergewaltigung ansehen
und habe dann erst in diesem raum
gesehen dass ich das bin und da ich
betäubt wurde unter k -o -tropfen habe
ich daran keinerlei erinnerung haben das
war wirklich aus dem komplett aus dem
normalen leben herausgerissen max h wird
zu drei jahren und vier monaten haft
verurteilt legte jedoch berufung ein max
h bleibt auf freiem fuß vor dem
berufungsprozess vor zwei wochen taucht
der vergewaltiger ab die fahndung läuft
zurück in hamburg auf dem kiez dort
haben viele junge frauen seit den
neuerlichen fällen in zwei klubs angst
davor selbst opfer einer ko tropfen
attacke zu werden
ja ich mache mir auf jeden fall gedanken
dass mir jemand ko-tropfen ins glas
machen könnte gerade wenn es viele
menschen auf einmal sind versuche meine
hand denn noch immer über ein glas zu
haben für sichere gefühl aber man hat
trotzdem bei jedem schluck angst dass
was sein könnte bei uns im kreis ist es
schon ein zwei mal vorgekommen und
dadurch ist man ein bisschen
vorsichtiger aber es passiert sehr
selten aber natürlich weiß man dass es
passieren kann wir haben man hat
natürlich immer bedenken dass ein bus
ins glas getan wird aber mir ist das
auch passiert ich habe schon generell
angst dass man beim feiern ko-tropfen
ins glas bekommt deshalb verpasst ihr
immer auf weil das getränk zubereitet
wird und auch der nachlass ist nirgends
unbeaufsichtigt stehen
die polizei ist hier auch der rapper man
natürlich immer mit einem großaufgebot
im einsatz
die beamten der weltbekannten davidwache
sind hier stände vor ort und haben
natürlich auch das meiste im blick aber
gerade in fällen wie angriffen mit ko
tropfen fällt es den beamten natürlich
sehr sehr schwer das beobachten zu
können und dann auch gleich zugreifen zu
können deswegen sind die ermittler
natürlich gerade in solchen fällen ganz
besonders auf hinweise von zeugen
angewiesen
und auch rettungswagenbesatzungen sollen
k -o -tropfen verdachtsfälle gezielt der
polizei melden
ja und über diese gefahr der k -o
-tropfen wollen wir sprechen mit dr
constantinis die bei uns ist unsere
achtung fahndung experte und
rechtsmedizinerin an der uniklinik
frankfurt guten abend genannt wir haben
ja einmal so grob vorbereitet auf um vor
allem zu zeigen wie schnell das denn
geht so zwei so spritzer ins getränk und
schon sieht das so aus als wäre alles da
drin vergiftet wie viel von solchen
spritzern braucht man denn tatsächlich
um wie sie es gerade vorgemacht haben
ganz wenig zwei bis drei milliliter
reichen zwei bis drei spritzer es geht
also ganz schnell und man braucht nicht
viel flüssigkeit dazu was genau passiert
da im körper beim menschen wenn man so
ko tropfen zu sich nimmt
die patienten werden oder die
betroffenen werden zitiert also sie
reagieren sehr schnell diese ko-tropfen
zeigen auch ein werk eintritt von
wenigen minuten 10 15 minuten sagt man
schon und die werden dann auffällig für
das was sie sonst konsumiert haben
häufig ist alkohol im spiel viel zu
betrunken dass betten berichten die
anderen betroffenen dann auch oder die
zeugen und sie werden dann letztendlich
sediert und benommen wenn es zu einer
überdosis gekommen ist können sie ins
koma fallen wenn jemand mit ko-tropfen
ins krankenhaus kommt wie werden die
nachgewiesen
man versucht die körperflüssigkeiten
blut und urin zu gewinnen und für manche
medikamente und drogen gibt schnelltests
dann kann man so relativ schnell
herausfinden um was es sich genau
handelt im wesentlichen muss man sich
aber an den symptomen der patienten
orientieren und entsprechend behandelt
und wahrscheinlich sind diese symptome
hat auch relativ nah an alkohol dran bis
auf dann eben dieser totale noch also
ist es das ist das problem das häufig
eben weil ja gerne in alkoholische
getränke eingemischt wird dass man die
alkoholwirkung immer auch noch hat das
heißt man ist sehr darauf angewiesen wie
die anamnese also die auffälligkeit der
person war und das müssen oft die
anderen beschreiben weil die person
selbst meistens dazu nicht mehr in der
lage ist also man orientiert sich an den
symptomen und man therapiert dann auch
symptomatisch und versucht so eben auch
die diagnose zu stellen gibson gegengift
etwas was man nehmen könnte um die
wirkung auszuschalten ja für manche
medikamente benzodiazepine zum beispiel
kann man ahnt organisieren aber auch
opiate die typische partydroge oder
diese racetruck ghb dafür gibt es leider
kein gegengift und die ist auch nur sehr
schwer nachzuweisen das heißt man muss
in ein speziallabor gehen das heißt gibt
auch kein vortest was ghb beim
nachweisen könnte und man muss dann eben
seine blut oder urinproben in speziellen
labors übergeben also da bleibt am ende
wirklich nur was wir gerade im beitrag
gehört haben auf das eigene getränk
aufpassen und vielleicht noch auf das
getränk der freundin mit aufpassen so
ist ist das ist sicher der einer der
besten ratschläge und nicht wie in
vielen dank dass sie heute bei uns waren
danke für ihre expertise und
wir haben es gehört nach unseren
informationen
da haben sich diese ko-tropfen fälle in
hamburg und in der umgebung von hamburg
in den letzten wochen gehäuft und die
polizei die braucht deshalb ihre hilfe
und fragt wer hat beobachtungen gemacht
hinweise nehmen die ermittler unter 040
4286 50 entgegen und die polizei bittet
eben ganz gezielt es sollen sich auch
die
rettungswagenbesatzungen die eben
ko-tropfen verdachtsfälle in der
jüngeren vergangenheit behandelt haben
bei der polizei melden
[Musik]